[Music]
hey what's going on and Happy Holidays
hot ones fans you're probably looking at
this like what this is a hot ones this
is different what is going on why is it
there by himself when I was growing up I
always used to hate when family matters
or Saved by the Bell these shows that
I'd watch when they do a clip show I'd
always be like hey you're mailing it in
this isn't a real episode and then BAM
Here I am my show doing the exact same
thing
I'm gonna give a behind the music a
behind the scenes a little behind the
hot sauce on some of my favorite moments
from season two strap up let's get it
cracking
[Music]
no I don't so just stand
there's no better place to start than
Coolio's dab and as anyone who watches
the episode knows Coolio is just poker
face all the way through wasn't even
flinching on winged 7 winged 8 but then
finally on winged 10 I'm not sure if it
was bravado or all the screwdrivers that
he slugged down but for whatever reason
Coolio decided I'm gonna douse this last
wing and half a bottle of Blair's
Megadeth sauce with liquid rage I know
and understand and appreciate the
consequences of that action which is why
I was so panicky legitimately I was like
we're gonna take out Coolio I know it
just looks like a studio but this is a
full-blown office building with people
running around cubicles phones ring in
the rest across the way is our green
room and it's all glass Coolio walks out
of the studio to the green room passes
out in the couch which is very bizarre
for all the people who work here you
just see a 90s rap legend passed out in
a green room couch nearing death it
looked like a modern art installation
whoo my mess is sweating next up Bobby
Lee Bobby Lee Jesus Christ like where do
I even start with Bobby Lee just an
emotional roller coaster from start to
finish
of course what everybody asks me about
is that finale that 10 wing incident
that something just happened yeah hold
up hold up aah
no now Bobby Lee has pooped on a lot of
shows before more so than any other
person in Hollywood I'd venture to say
so it's not like it's that shocking or
like that's surprising but here's what
I'll say sometimes the energy in the
room doesn't fully translate to the
video during the Jay Pharoah interview
for example when he was doing those
impressions everyone in this room had
their jaws on the floor and the video is
amazing but you kind of need to see that
happen in real time right next to you to
fully appreciate what happened I would
say that the same is true for the Bobby
Lee 10th Wing incident it is a
disconcerting noise to say the least but
in real time sitting across the table
during what seemed to me to be a semi
serious situation that sound had some
serious life that did not get picked up
by the boom or by his mic and that's all
I'm gonna say
key & peele another episode that people
talk about and I think what sticks out
to me was afterwards key and Peele you
know during that whole thing it's
amazing to see the way they work off of
each other in real time as we maybe be
hugging joints don't join cos hey any
person that comes in to a room that it
just looks huggable you know so he'd be
like give me hugging joints no don't be
drinking water how'd it do it but then
afterwards they get up from the table
and the two of them are still doing hot
sauce jokes with each other they're
walking down the hallway and I can see
them bouncing back and forth with more
hot sauce gags it's just the two of them
and a publicist walking down the hallway
then when they meet up with their teams
I can hear them like on the other side
of the wall still doing hot sauce jokes
with each other a Trojan horse with that
sweetness that's at home that's that's a
ah
Genghis Khan just rode through my
consoles
what's going on here whoo Knoxville the
TJ Miller episode TJ Miller I think that
that was a real turning point in the
history uh I think TJ would admit this
he doesn't always love being interviewed
uh but he's a huge hot sauce guy and
right when he sat down I think he
understood what we were about and I
quickly was like very into it plus he
gave us the water bottle explosion and
for that will forever be indebted
the Jay Pharoah episode obviously no
great hot sauce stories because anybody
who watched the show knows that he
bodied the ten wings but immediately
after his hot ones shoot to an
enraptured audience of just hot ones
production people Jay Pharoah spits
sixty-four bars as Cassidy and we're all
just like watching it we're like this is
amazing like what the hell is going on
and it was like so dope and then we were
like yo where's that clip at and they're
like Oh we'd stop running the cameras
which was very hot one so that is
forever gone but you can't take it away
from my memory you know it doesn't
really baby but you know I'm just trying
to be I'm just trying to clear my vocal
cords because it's a lot of mucus build
uh-oh and the cord I it's delicious
[ __ ]
I love these wings Joe Budden episode if
someone were to ask me what I think is
the best moment of season two I would
say Joe Budden tenth wing showdown
challenged me to a [ __ ] hot sauce
jewel all right now let's talk about me
and chili Klaus eating the Carolina
Reaper in Central Park took a lot of
heat for this because during the Aragon
Dre episode I said that I wouldn't eat
another Carolina Reaper for less than
five figures don't know what my bottom
dollar would be to ever do it again but
it would be like five figures I wouldn't
do it for less than so maybe sick sick
painful dying did Shawn get paid of
course Shawn didn't get paid but here's
the deal
I can't say no to chili Klaus that's my
whole thing it's easy for me to posture
it's easy for me to play hardball it's
easy for me to be a tough guy until
chili Klaus picks up the phone and goes
hello Sean I'm coming to New York I
would like to eat a spicy pepper again
like when he does that to me like what
if what would you do what would you do
what would you do it just pulls at the
heartstrings I you can't say no to chili
class that guy could have me drinking
Carolina Reaper flavored Drano on his
YouTube channel and I'd do it for free
because I love him also shout out that
poor woman who was just trying to get
some UV rays on a Wednesday afternoon
when all of a sudden chili Klaus comes
barreling out of the horse-and-buggy
with a half gallon of milk and just
starts the projectile vomiting in her
general space on behalf of hot ones
Central Park we apologize
oh what a hole what am i the Rachael Ray
spoon episode Thanksgiving classic
immediate hot ones classic took a lot of
heat about not telling Rachel about the
hot sauce on her nose and I think that
now is the perfect time to come clean on
this one okay there's so many lights in
my face like I don't really see the
person in front of me with like the same
detail as you do once the videos made so
I didn't see it I didn't notice it
everybody to me looks beet red by the
fourth wing anyway I don't think that I
owe anyone an apology except for my
woman crush every day Rachael Ray to
Rachel I'm sorry that's my bad and
that's on me and there's no excuse but
to everyone else coming at my neck for
that one I don't owe you anything okay
how are our views on this one they're
not good roll the boob sweat clip boob
sweat a river runs through it alright
that's a wrap for holiday special and
before I go I just want to say thank you
for rockin with us in 2016 I want to say
Happy Holidays to all the hot ones fans
out there I hope that your stocking is
stuffed with hot sauce and as one final
gift we've asked our editors Anna a Kyle
Chris Murphy to put together one last
one shining moment type of video clip
for the hot ones fans roll the tape
hey what's going on everybody first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones in hot ones teen hot ones the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wings oh my god as intros ready to get
it going
ready to do this I love you I love you
too you ready do this no oh oh my god
Oh hit me right there oh I get it
gosh yeah I'm drunk out like I'm drunk
[ __ ] Tinashe where you were
OOP I got a dime oh I'm feeling some
[ __ ] what's the point
on your blog live in one crash it behind
the crash wait
alright it but I'm give me just a second
you walk [ __ ] laughs oh my god he woke
up the laughs is very important
suck my dick outside whoa don't do this
I love lip I'll see you the hell cool
don't order the wings just keep your
feet planted on your hat I keep reaching
for the stops
[Music]